foreign
thank you very much
dear Madam president
journalists
dear ladies and gentlemen we have
started
two very important European integration
days in Ukraine today we have
negotiations with Madam president of the
European commission Ursula Funderland
and there will also be a joint meeting
of the European commission and the
government of Ukraine tomorrow we have
Simon the Ukraine Summit and
this is the time when our joint
agreements in here in cave in our
Capital will will mean the strengthening
of entire Europe increase of our
cooperation through the integration
Ukraine's integration to the European
Union means strengthening of the
pan-european possibilities to defend
life the defend life of free people in
free
Europe something that the founding
fathers of the European Union have been
dreaming of in different countries and
they dreamed of Europe to be reliably
protected against any aggression
chauvinism
and forced distribution of borders
they dreamed of democracy in Europe and
defended rights of each person defended
rights of each Community they dreamed
of never having the time when there
would be burnt cities and deportation in
Europe in order to fulfill this dream of
peaceful Europe we can this can be done
only with Ukraine and by winning over
Russia Ursula you probably remember when
we worked for such a great and important
step for our country as the candidate
status for Ukraine
Ukraine's membership in the European
Union I mentioned it to you that for our
people it's really important for our
people it is a motivation
it is a motivation to defend our state
first of all and consequently the entire
Europe against the biggest anti-european
forces in the world why this motivation
ukrainians at the battlefield defend
specifically those values that Europe
has got United on and keeps uniting and
we cannot lose it so every step to
bigger unification Union between Ukraine
and the European Union inspires our
people and this gives a result to the
entire Europe it gives the result to our
society in order to get defended against
the our joint enemy so the next logical
step
uh it is a logical step for and to
towards our historic uh Union and the
membership in the European Union will be
uh taken with the same inspiration as
the candidate status and you Russia is
now getting uh concentrate it's
concentrating forces and getting ready
uh to take revenge not only against
Ukraine but also against you pre-europe
and the entire world and unfortunately
to win over this enemy it's not enough
to have victories only in the
battlefield it's important to have the
belief in Europe in peaceful Europe
United Europe we need the strength of
our institutions we need the motivating
in European integration achievements
that will show that the uh the strengths
of our people on the battlefield and at
all levels of this very difficult uh
fight is supported by the entire group
dear ladies and gentlemen dear Ursula
today and tomorrow we are working with
the European partners
specifically for these achievements
in order to prepare the next phase of
our integration with the European Union
in order to strength our defense against
Russian aggression in particular we are
talking about financial economic social
energy humanitarian issues and of course
for Ukraine's reconstruction dear
now that Madam president has passed over
a report on the second part of the
questionnaire that Ukraine has fulfilled
when we were getting our candidate
status I am really glad that this is so
thin it's it's a good news this
report will become the basis for the
work of our government officials but I
think that we will speak in more detail
during the joint meeting that we are
going to open together
uh this is the joint meeting between the
government of Ukraine the European
Commission Now together with uh Madam
president with Ursula we have discussed
the key issues related to Ukraine and
the European Union and I would like to
give one specific example something that
characterizes other sides of our very
important and tight cooperation we have
agreed with Madam Ursula that the
European commission will help us to
start the reform
of the uh the system for the protection
of children and care for children it's
very important for us the children who
do not have parental care
for the pride of Parental care and
instead of the system of
Internet of the orphanage houses which
are the heritage of these Soviet times
we want to establish and you uh system
of the family houses that will be done
on the basis on the systemic basis and
it will be a very important reform for
our children and this is not only an
Institutional change
the war is pushing us forward this is an
important civilizational change for
Ukraine it is an absolutely different
attitude to a human it is the proper
correct attitude to families and to
society in general and to know that the
first ladies team will also meet with
Madame van derland with Ursula and they
will discuss this and other very
important humanitarian issues in the
cooperation with European commission we
have also submitted we have also
confirmed the necessity to uh to
continue liberalization of trade between
Ukraine U and Ukraine and European Union
we have talked about the financial and
economic stability of Ukraine European
commission support is very important the
high priority for our country we have
talked a lot about the Reconstruction
there has been many discussions in
Europe as to the recovery of our country
after because still it is over now is
the time for more specific things fast
recovery is important very important
fast recovery
and quick recovery and it's important to
ensure they find the financial support
to this process it's a priority we also
Implement our joint program with the
European Commission on the on to
rational to improve the energy
consumption in Ukraine in particular
free exchange of incandescent lamps by
the LED lamps and I am really I would
like to thank personally to usla for
this program and 5 million LED lamps
have already that have been funded by
the European commission European Union
have already been sent to Ukraine and
this will result in considerable
decrease of deficit of energy
consumption Ukraine we have talked about
the increase of the input of energy
supplies to Ukraine in order to have the
energy
of our people to have also relevant
protection the energy area we have
discussed the sanctions against Russia
in particular the tense package this is
the Joint
Task for the for Europe in order to cut
the circumvention of sanctions and the
mobile and the more we do it the closer
we will be to the defeat of Russian
aggression we see that sanction speed in
Europe has slowed down a little bit and
uh Russian the terrorist state is
speeding up its adaptation to sanctions
so it's important to for us to speed up
and to to correct the situation and I do
believe that together we will be able to
do this just like we will also be able
to meet all other expectations in
Ukraine and the in the in Europe thank
you very much for your attention thank
you very much for this very uh for very
important subjects that we have
discussed at the beginning of our
European integration days
um it's good to be back and let me
mirror what you uh just said about our
meeting indeed this is my fourth time my
fourth visit and this time I did not
come alone I brought along the College
of Commissioners my team of
Commissioners and by having
the College of Commissioners and the
Ukrainian government basically gathered
around the same workbench
we are able now to work not only on
sustaining the Ukrainian people now but
also to build how to build a future of
Ukraine in the European Union
it has been almost one year since Putin
launched his brutal Invasion one year of
suffering
but also of legendary bravery by the
Ukrainian people
and one year of impressive Unity by the
global community
Europe has been by Ukraine's side since
day one
because we know that the future of our
continent is being written here
we know that you are fighting for more
than yourselves
what is at stake is freedom
this is a fight of democracies
against authoritarian regimes
Putin tries to deny the existence of
Ukraine but what he risks instead is the
future of Russia
our presence in gift today gives a very
clear signal the whole of the European
Union is in this with Ukraine for the
Long Haul
and we will stand up for Ukraine as we
stand up for the fundamental rights and
the respect of the international law
and that's my first point is indeed you
mentioned it two ensuring Economic
Security for Ukraine
we made a promise last year that is
stable predictable financial support
and we've kept This Promise
two weeks ago we delivered the first
tranche of our 18 billion financial
assistance for 2023
overall the European Union's economic
humanitarian and Military Support for
Ukraine
amounts since the beginning of the war
to almost 50 billion euros now
it is important for us
to
give Economic Security to our friends in
Ukraine
we are also helping to ensure the energy
security you mentioned it too
unremeting attacks on Ukrainian
infrastructure are targeted he tries to
subject the Ukrainian people to a brutal
winter with little heat power and water
but we are working together tirelessly
to restore vital energy infrastructure
it starts in Ukrainian homes
from this week on indeed the LED light
bulbs are available to Ukrainian
citizens at the post office
these are the first batches of the 30
million LED light bulbs we promised but
in fact I'm happy to announce that we
can overshoot our goal we are now able
to provide 35 million LED light bulbs
we are delivering equipment to keep
Ukrainian grit the Ukrainian grid
functioning and we're making sure that
electricity is flowing through the grid
despite the attacks so it's very
Hands-On what we do very practical today
for example I can announce that we are
providing 2 400 additional generators
they come on top of the three thousand
already delivered since the beginning of
the war
and alongside with the member states in
the energy Community we will make
available over 150 million euros to
purchase vital energy equipment for
Ukraine
finally we are inviting Ukraine to our
energy platform for joint purchasing of
gas you know the principle we want to
make the best use of our joint Market
power
so we will overcome this winter dear
Vladimir and many others to come
to working on the mid and long term of
energy
therefore together we start to develop
renewable energy sources
you have said recently valadimir Ukraine
intense and I cite you to become a
leader
in building modern green energy
and rightly so this is the right goal
and it's possible to achieve it
Renewables will not only bring clean
energy they will also increase Ukraine's
energy security
because they are homegrown
and because a decentralized Energy
System is plain and simply safer
so we are now working on making
available significant funding funding
for solar panels
that will be deployed across Ukraine
we will call on member states and
trusted Partners to join this initiative
the aim is
to power public buildings
so to provide stable supplies to
hospitals to fire departments or schools
for instance with these solar panels on
the public buildings
a final element in the energy Security
today we're assigning a memorandum of
understanding on renewable gases
such as biomethane or hydrogen
so very concrete steps in the direction
of Ukraine's green reconstruction
and indeed reconstruction is the big
overarching topic
we are in this fight together
and we will rebuild this beautiful
country together
and here let me briefly Focus
reconstruction Starts Now with fast
recovery
so we work now together on making it
available on making available one
billion euros for the start of the fast
recovery
we can start right away with that fast
recovery and with these one billion but
of course more is to be added to that
the big topic as I said the overarching
topic is reconstruction and here the
world is mobilizing
the G7 bonus coordination platform is
now in place
the platform will help coordinate the
international assistance and will
support your reform agenda
then there is an engine a motor that is
the Secretariat that is led by
representatives of your government and
the commission and that Secretariat is
present here both in Kiev and in
Brussels
seven countries and Beyond as well as
International financial institutions
I'm now preparing to send people to
Second it's a Convent by experts to the
Secretariat so that we are now pooling
the efforts to make economic recovery
and reconstruction a success
my second message today is that we are
making Putin pay for his atrocious work
before Russia started this war
we were very vocal
about the severe economic costs we will
impose on Russia if it invades Ukraine
and today Russia is paying a heavy price
as our sanctions are eroding its economy
throwing it back by a generation
the price cap on crude oil already costs
Russia around 160 million euros a day
and we will keep on turning up the
pressure further
we will introduce with our G7 partners
an additional price cap on Russian
petroleum products
and by the 24th of February exactly one
year since the invasion started we aim
to have the 10th package of sanctions in
place
Russia will also have to pay for the
destruction it cost and will have to
contribute to the Reconstruction of
Ukraine therefore we are exploring with
our partners how to use Russia's public
assets to the benefit of Ukraine
and Russia must be held accountable in
courts for its odious crimes
prosecutors from Ukraine and the
European Union are already working
together
we are collecting evidence
and as a first step I'm pleased to
announce that an international center
for the prosecution of the crime of
aggression in Ukraine will be set up in
The Hague
this Center will coordinate the
collection of evidence
it will be embedded in the joint
investigation team which is supported by
our agency eurojust
so we will be ready to launch work very
rapidly with your just with Ukraine with
the partners of our joint investigation
team as well as with the Netherlands
the perpetrator must be held accountable
my third message today is about
Ukraine's integration in the European
Union
your stamina and your people stamina and
your determination to join the European
Union is impressive
you prepared your application for the
European union membership brilliantly I
know it by experience you became a
candidate country while fighting an
invasion
you continue to make impressive progress
to meet the seven steps of the
commission's opinion
I'm comforted to see that your
anti-corruption bodies are on alert and
effective in detecting corruption cases
I also commend you on reacting so
rapidly at the political level
to make sure that the fight against
corruption is delivering tangible
results and it is further stepped up
and while Ukraine advances on the
European path We are tearing down
barriers between our economies and
societies even further
today we are proposing to Ukraine to
join key European programs
this will give Ukraine benefits close to
those of EU membership in many areas
and we will discuss this now in our
working session with the ministers and
the Commissioners and I will be happy to
give more details than afterwards in the
next press conference
my final point and it is last but
certainly not least
um that we are connecting more and more
our people our companies and our cities
last year you called for our cities to
twin the twin Partnerships and they
heard you and they are doing it
so let me report you that we have now
100 large cities in the European Union
that are twinned with 36 Ukrainian
cities by now
Munich with kiev for example turku with
kharkif
almost 1 000 smaller towns in the
European Union have Partnerships with
municipalities in Ukraine with
uromaras correct
good pronunciation very good you
understood what I meant good
later on you tell me Holt correctly
pronounced
and just like you called they are ready
to help to rebuild the sister cities in
Ukraine
so our Network for Euro cities has
already launched a project on the
sustainable rebuilding of cities in
Ukraine and I think it is amazing
because there are urban planners
Engineers Architects fully on board and
the new European Bauhaus concept will
inspire them
they partner in Ukraine to launch the
capacity building program for example
they share knowledge
for rebuilding smartly for example by
recycling concrete
so that Ukraine could use half of the
debris from destroyed buildings to
rebuild better
our Live program will provide the first
steps on that this is 7 million for the
program to start so our vision is
to turn the destruction
of War into opportunities to build a
beautiful and Healthy Future for Ukraine
this war of aggression has broken so
many lives
the first lady Elena zelenska told me
indeed about the immense suffering
of the children that are left orphans
Putin's War has taken away their parents
and has shattered their lives
and we cannot mend this but we can offer
to comfort their pain and to help the
best we can
not in institutions as you said but in
family-based care
we want these children to grow up in a
loving environment that gives them
confidence and strength
so be reassured
we will support Ukraine to provide the
best possible care for these orphans we
will share our experience we will offer
financial support we are starting with
10 million euro to support here the
designing of a modern Child Care
strategy and this includes of course
capacity building and a training project
because I think it is wise that Ukraine
teams up with European member states
who have gone through the same process
so have the experience what to avoid and
what the best practice is
we cannot bring back the parents to
these children but we can carry their
future in our minds and in our hearts
and do the best for them
so the evolution our teams are rolling
up their sleeves they're already working
we have more than 20 topics on our
workbench today so it's a lot to discuss
it's wonderful to be again here and I'm
very much looking forward to the
discussions this afternoon
[Music]
in the afternoon